[Musica]
oggi challenge 24 ore epica il
premiolino berlino deciderò per 24 ore
che si scorda marzio quindi lui deciderà
anche di matri rete meglio mangiare
umore che compensa le zingarate rm
perché che berlino ha dei gusti un po
particolari alcun assenso commentato
solo ogni volta che accettiamo la
videocamera si addormenta e restano nome
è un fatto perché corre da una parte
all'altra e mercatino comunque marino e
deciderò sottoposto a maggio per questi
questo colore è lasciato brevi piace se
volesse vedere altre challenge 24 ore
assicuratevi di vedere il video fino
alla fine perché si sarà una parola
segreta nascosta per altri video che
dovrete riuscire a coprirla in mattina
quindi iniziamo con la colazione
io sto morendo di fame quindi spero
tanto che berlino insegnerà qualcosa di
buono per me vero ha detto da uno show
davvero io voglio tutto allora abbiamo
pressioni perché l'azione la prima
azione è una torta al cioccolato berlino
facendo che stai facendo è cosa devi
guardare fuori d'onda opzioni abbiamo
anzi anche lo torturava bravissimo va
bene dei fichi secchi rinsecchiti e
bollette
quindi berlino non deve scegliere se
avete ascoltato barry racconta non
genere questo va bene
questa non è vigente tu devi seguire
questa offerta è capito miracoli legno
con la cappella come manovale in sogno a
fargli scegliere a fargliene scegliere
vedremo tre scatole in cui chiuderemo
questi dentro la prima casa del cui io
ero a berlino sarà quello che dovrò
mangiare preparazione del viaggio
certo i disegni sterlina
no no secchi ok pure di questi due
settimane io ho il mattino ha annusato
del gct ragazzino le scatole della frode
consisteva prima dobbiamo fare
domenica tra tutti che distrugge le
scatole di batteria ma siccome lasci
fuori non mi fido tanto va bene ci sei
racket
[Musica]
no io ci casco più
io sto qua da blue cat giornata la
faccia dire bene allora vediamo che
soldi alla causa dei botti scherzo che
c'è però c'è tra scatole
vediamo che desidero farmi fanno che
tutte le altre ma la primaria giocatore
ma che fa di mattia coda fa venivamo
[Musica]
perché non perdona tutti ma la maggiore
di una cosa allora vediamo che disse no
domani in volo io sto magnago da figure
non mi voglio la scatola per arrestarlo
perché la seconda che toccato è questa
quindi sempre più sarebbe potuta essere
una cosa che avrei potuto mangiare
vediamo in base al tipo che c'è emma
bonino ha visto meglio tutti
buoni posticino sono un po di cartone
vero
graziani è un fico secco molliccio
sembrava una lumaca come allora casi gas
dai che sono buoni fichi secchi tesi
oppure un morbidini non sono neanche
troppo secchi e molliccia guardate che
delizioso berlino est e berlino di ha
scelto quelli perché li vorrebbe
mangiare lui e che guidò secondo me dati
non piacciono nemmeno a lui si è rimasti
cherebbe comunque perché è un cane
mangia tutto come mai spiegherebbe tutto
[Musica]
e il vedete magi fichi secchi sono i
fichi secchi blumenthal è ottimo la mia
30 di maturazione dei momenti perché
vedere stavano i cavoli page i vecchi
quindi berlino berlino nel frattempo
entrato nella modalità tumore
agitatissimo
si va quindi un under in angolo oggi
imparare a gestire l'uso più dura però
abbiamo il mio bravo bravo bravo bravo
vedete che ha mosso attivo detto ma
questo era un po più agitato grazie
bravo divertendo vediamo cosa si aspetta
lasciando un qualcosa di delizioso
perché ho bisogno di dimostrare qualcosa
[Musica]
ma il tempo tetto del mattino si sta per
me la cosa metto nel mio mi raccomando
se di questo questo disegno
ho già scelto ma mia mamma e questo è
rimanente delle patate 3 contro 3
impegnata berlino si recava ogni altro
ed allegria
[Musica]
se ti piace però a berlino anni muore
al contrario non c'è niente questo
piatto niente altrimenti non è che
abbiamo promesso e almeno e due opzioni
commestibili alla tv perché andiamo a
preparare le scatole chiediamo cosa
segnerà a berlino è la tesi a berlino
posizione amo le scatole
ok siamo pronti ok facciamolo entrare
perché voglio vedere cosa figlio minore
cosa dire anche prendere fa capire la
prima che hanno usato e la scatola verde
nello scatolone tema ma veniamo a
conoscenza ma avevo un bagno di struzzi
meno magno tutta l'ira e mi ha detto che
non è sempre calmo e addormentato
aspettare se qua dentro
ho recuperato la scatola berlino si era
portata fino alla sua come voglio
polemista rabon e lascia dobbiamo aprire
questa allora vediamo un po che apprese
patatine lui lui e scelte le fa da dire
[Risate]
ho scelto io devo dire a berlino perché
[Applauso]
[Risate]
maledetta per noi ma per una
dirò io la mattina non è buon altro di
modelli che la baciano ma non sembra
buono può sempre ringraziare una prima
per aver scelto il limone merlino
stasera è meglio che sembra qualcosa di
buono brevetti morire di fame
mangiare e degli affetti lo mangi però
dai si sente fino a qui successo limando
arrivare di temi si è riusciti a sentire
l'odore del limone da sentite bello
ascom sulla lingua o pezzo a noi lo
studio cercava puoi lanciare il monito
sull'umore arriva la buona mi vuole a
berlino ascoltami bene tutto estermi del
vangelo quarto capitolo di tipo
oramai viaggio timone un pochettino
allora perché la buccia è cosa buona che
guarda a volta the visions sento ha
agito fin da qui nel vino mi stanno
guardando perde sta controllando e tra
davvero mangiando addio potrebbe sempre
la situazione va bene almeno dal pezzo
di silicio la vitamina c di cosa mangerà
e altro
te lo dico io o un altro punto di dimore
mangerai questo brutto tempo almeno sei
coperto dove domina c1 intanto intento a
fissare fuori dalla fine tiro ma tumori
di piazza ma come bambino io direi che
volevo mangiarlo lui non volevo che
l'omaggio bio
20 berlino ascoltami bene ascoltami
[Musica]
qualcosa di buono hai capito crocchette
bernina ho scelto le crocette ma per me
continuare cannes e berlino buona
memoria per cena se di qualcosa di buono
bisogno di fare qualcosa
quelle sono le opzioni per ce lo siamo
dimenticati di dirvi una cosa
importantissima e cioè pesante seguito
per un po o se siete voi dolari diciamo
ci sarà una nuova serie sul mio canale
vita stories ed è una dei super mega man
tattica è veramente una cosa pazzesca
che non è mai stata fatta prima su
youtube italia quindi non potete neanche
immaginare
che cosa è la nuova serie non vi posso
volere troppe cose perché una sorpresa
però vi dico una cosa importantissima
il 15 maggio ci sarà un video sulla come
vedere un video pazzesco è super
fantastico quindi facciamo andiamo il
conto alla rovescia
io ogni giorno soprattutto stilista
calmo dimetterò un piccolo indizio ogni
15 maggio guida nato a mettere la
sveglia perché sono parte con il video e
sarà finalmente uno spoiler sulla
serietà prete che cos'è finalmente
quindi segnatevi le date del calendario
15 maggio i primi indizi che vi dò io
molti qualcuno è riuscito finale
finora nessuno è dominato è che una
serie che non è mai stata fatta prima
d'ora su youtube italia che non riguarda
merlino perché tutti mi avete scritto da
per il suo merlino no non è una serie su
berlino
adesso se le super mega tattica questi
sono i tre indizi frode dominare nei
commenti lei non voleva
l'amarezza di pane berlino ascoltami
bene devi farmi mangiare ha detto ok 66
da sotto pure io averli notati dormendo
e arrivato il momento della cena
finalmente sto morendo di fame immagini
così ricorda anche berlino
vediamo vediamo le mamme ma una mega
maggiore due non devi scegliere questo
dei babbei e la mente già ketchup
ma torniamo di lì dedication anche
fatali e ben fatto di testavano prima
però scusami non probabile che scelga
che esatto lui perché se si è mangiato
prima il foglio con le patatine
magari adesso vogliono la zuppa buono
per adesso se avessi detto palma di
prevenire mangiare una pizza non
ministro né 9 mar nero perché questo
minestrone rino perché offre giorno
delle scarpe ultima laghezza capita
capita di ricevere la pizza visto
appreso ti prego io sono state allora
non mi ricordavo ci siamo tale asse
permettermi quello di netto forse tutti
va bene mettiamo genia mi piacciono su
tre
voglio qui a spa vero vorrei mangiare
berlino credo questo avverte prima
no non mi sembra proprio mandato
direttamente questo di fino e poi ha
deciso di strano chiesti questa scatola
allora per dire che di esposti possa
vedere che per the fame
ok siamo pronti a dire prima che amici è
arrivato qui
era allora almeno so che mi è capitato
il ketchup e lamela perché melania
meno male quindi c'è la possibilità che
io abbia una piccola finestra a
un'infezione tutto liscio per primo la
mia vita dai state già qui a messina
cavolo che pizza ma è enorme
[Musica]
cadeva per terra
sta prendendo così come non vi
[Applauso]
permettete al the fame che potrei
mangiare da cavo loro se ne è morto ma
non è neanche resistito crescendo reggio
in cugino a mangia farla direttamente
qui in studio lascio per un pezzo
d'ufficio non c'è bisogno sempre
dividerla con tutti no non è vero non ci
divide ma la pizza amicizia si mangia
tutta da come infatti è più grande di
testa pizza o e io ea berlino berlino
non può mangiare la finalità per pezzo
dai valore giusto questo non è di non
mangiare
[Musica]
vedo perchè non me l'hai chiesto lo ha
detto la frittata e non ci sarebbero
inviato perché stavo baranzate lo
mangiavo basta somma lanciato da sergio
tutto un migliaio è una matiz tami ha
capito che vanno ad aperture all'ora
prestabilita 24 ore è certo il barchino
che cosa mangiavano mi è piaciuta
lasciato per nike tributerà nocciole ma
non mi piace se volete che condivida una
tetta movie tales fa solo una fetta che
si sente come si sa perché attrezzate di
ventiquattr'ore volesse che facciamo
essere nei commenti
e allora vi lasciamo a quattro
cartellini e su cui giocare
cliccate su quella che preferite
[Musica]
[Applauso]